i'm not a sex toy person
are you ready to take a look at some
yeah okay we have this one
you know let me tell you about this toy
um this is a toy for people who fucked
their boppets when they were younger
twist it spin it flick it come on it
does look that's what it looks like do
you remember the skippet
yes i do the best part of all just a
counter on this ball
skip it it looks like a chunk it you
used to throw your dog's ball with yeah
yeah this looks like don't make a sex
toy that reminds me
of a toy i enjoyed as a child first of
all this does eight different things
how horny are you that you need to
sexually there's eight different things
it's too much put it on your balls put
in your ass
it's a coat rack like what sex is not
the time to multitask
i'd fuck up and i think this was a can
opener
look at it you can put it on your clit
and your boobs see
i this is around this man's shaft in her
butt and then his shaft is in her this
is for everyone
this makes me think my i'm deformed i
don't
know where i would put any of it i i
understand that i could put
the phallic part in my vagina i don't
the hook i don't know where that would
go they're showing you can go on your
nipple on your clit on his penis
look here here it is in her vagina and
then his penis is in her butt and then
it's around his penis
this is just like this is just your boy
it's so bored
i mean it's a lot you're just like kind
of trying to like check boxes and
it's like a scavenger hunt at this point
oh yeah but don't worry it gets weirder
we also have this
what it hey heard about ana i want to
give it a spin
this is this is a butt plug with a
fidget spinner on it but i
this is great if you're dating someone
who worked at a mall kiosk in 2016
or who has terrible anxiety when
confronted with your butthole
or by the way isn't that
fidget spinner to reduce stress yeah
anxiety and stress let me tell you
something
by the way why are you if you have
anxiety and stress just
don't have anal sex you know what's
really stressful
knowing you have to have anal sex in a
couple hours if you've introduced this
toy
you don't have anxiety you've cured it
this is the trick
this if you put this inside someone it
better spin fast enough they can take
off and fly away from your domination
it's weird i i feel like i'm a fun
good at sex person but i've i've not
used but
blood plug blood plug i see i'm getting
nervous and
[Music]
what did they do they fill you up here's
one with the tail
this is a raccoon skin hat for sex
addicts
that's what this is this is this is a
butt plug for everyone that stormed the
capitol
this person wants too much attention
wearing this let me tell you this
too much attention you want the
attention of a lover and my pet
absolutely not that's too much fucking
attention but it's also like
hair okay i'll just i could also just
grow my pubes back
they make these as horsetails too
no well they're not made out of the
actual animals this is all foe
oh okay what is that are people actually
pretending they're horses and
yeah they are they're like yeah they
were a mask and a tail oh my god
frolic we've got her that sounds
like so much work i feel like
yeah none of this seems easy i was gonna
say i feel like
we've moved past easy looking at all
these making rallies like insects i am
so
lazy well it gets better because the
next one have any props
that's what i want you to close your
eyes for okay okay i'll tell you when to
open
this is i just want you know this is the
internet's ideal woman
opening my eyes you can go ahead and
open your eyes now
this is for fans of dexter who have gone
too far
this isn't real now listen again
i'm a sweet boy i don't want to king
shame anyone i literally
i'm not upset with anybody liking
anything we've talked about or what we
have shown
but this has tested me this is really
pushing it okay we're in some
we're in a place you i have one foot out
the door
i really do have you ever wanted to fuck
the foot of a plague victim
here's what i'll say with a pedicure
this she has look at the look at the
rash on this person's
is this a living i truly thought it was
a halloween decoration
i don't think i would have could be i
don't think i would have even put it
together whose foot is gray and dead
like
so hold on french manicures are those
jails is this a
is this the the fact that they gave her
a french gel manicure is that
and then put a red infection around it i
want to zoom in on that red infection oh
god this foot's dead it has to be it's a
severed foot it's the idea that it's a
dead foot i mean look at the color
wait so this is like a ted bundy like
this is like this foot has herpes
athlete's foot this foot is in gray
scale um
do you wait is the idea that this is
people that want to fuck
feet or that it has to be it has to be
this has to be
but i feel like if your fucking feet
this is more you're fucking the bone of
a foot
oh this is the foot you'd be if you were
just in love with the foot where else
would its pussy be
i mean here's my question if you're into
this and that's cool
sure if you're into this eventually
you'll be over this and what's the next
step are you shoving prosthetic legs up
your ass what's happening yeah
this is is this a a gateway this is a
gateway drug the gateway drug
do you have any personal feelings i i
like
i just feel like if this is
should be illegal
unless you love it then we're here for
him like there's someone in a factory
that has to like put the foot in the on
the
thing and then i just i feel all i can
think about is the person that had to
like
oh yeah imagine finding this in your
lover's room imagine finding this freak
what happens is this frankenstein
toe-ass pussy in your
if i found this what would you do a sock
in a shoe you're madly in love with
someone you find this in their
closet what do you do is it wearing a
knock on the shoe like in my story
because the first question i have is
shoes and socks come in pairs where the
rest of them like they
tried to make it intentionally the
toenails are bleeding
so gross and that's okay if you like it
we love it um but i do have another
here's the you were talking about how
it's
how toys get very they're either scary
like this
or they're extremely childish and
terrifying
like i don't think sex toys should look
like a children's toy
children should be the least dazzled by
a sex toy why are they all made to look
like this
in like colors and sparkles and glitter
like
am i cumin on it i just don't think sex
has to be this
cute complicated this looks i mean
you could put this on the shelf in a
kid's aisle and
who know the difference don't do that
that's gross yeah you could
yeah yeah no this looks like a lisa
frank like trapper keeper
do you think it's collaboration
is this a is this a jeffree star
is this is this sex ex lisa frank
is this a lisa frank sex toy i mean it's
it's it's
also what is it a butterfly what it is i
feel like the sex toy business
wants to wants to capitalize on our 90s
nostalgia
but reminds me of the 90s
and i in a time when i like shouldn't
have been having sex you know what i
mean it looks like a jelly it's back to
foot shit like
yes jellies the shoes yeah yep why does
it have to have glitter on it that's my
thing that's it's very like
it's very like cute a lot of sex toys
they add glitter and stuff
it's too cute it's for children it looks
like a kid's toy
the next one is the o-ring this is great
if you forgot how to open your own mouth
you know what okay so is this for dicks
or uh for dick sucking i think this is
for if you go in a haunted house
you know but you're spooked everyone i'm
so that's what i think
if you have too much botox i think it
knows your emotion from my understanding
when i
when i screen grab the picture for this
it is for coming into
like a little bowl i think this would be
helpful if you wanted to like
you know eat a bunch of chicken nuggets
at once it's like
there's i mean there are uses for this
for sure but i just don't know like
how much calm can there be
that you need to i know like who do you
think you are
what are you are you gargling it like
but i do
i i do find myself in sexual situations
where i'll either start laughing
and i'm like i wish i wish i had
something and you think this would make
it less funny yes
no i'm just saying like on my serious
face
no but i think that's why i like are you
lucky when a guy has like whether it's
like a ball gag or like a thing i'm like
oh thank god
that's why i like wearing the mask
because like i can crack up laughing if
something
because i when a guy tries a new sex
move like from porn
i like can't help but laugh i just want
to know a situation
where this is introduced to you when
it's like i have this device
that i think it'd be really easy for me
to piss directly in your mouth no you'd
have to buy this for yourself and
and wear it yeah show up just come out
wearing it this is a hard
thing to introduce in a sexual
relationship but i
it's like my thing is like oh god if
this like makes you
if they're into this godspeed well the
next one is
the pleasure toy and what i've learned
from this process of looking at these
sex toys is that nobody wants to fuck a
person
no a what nobody wants to fuck a person
they just want to fuck
things just objects that's my takeaway
from this this looks like a shoe
stretcher
yeah look at this shoe doesn't seem like
that thing in it you know it looks like
a
mouse like on a mouse oh yeah if you
want to pretend your pussy is a mouth
pad
that's what this is for sure this is the
new apple tv remote actually
steve jobs is going to come up we'll
talk about in a minute it looks like one
of those little stones you put in a
garden like mom's put in the garden you
know like
wishes yes totally what is this design
on it design is like
it's like a 58 year old art teacher
painted that on there
like inspirational rock that says like
faith yeah you literally buy this
like a as like a street fair somewhat
like we charged it in the moon
no you didn't well that's the last of
them
that's the last those are all the
options of sex toys can you believe
i yeah i'm not one realistic dick or
vagina can you believe
i well the last thing i'll say is what
like
the sex toys it's like they always have
to have like veins and
they try to like for your pleasure i
feel like there's a
there uh the sex toy industry is torn
between making things super fantastical
like we're gonna make like a
sparkly pink butterfly like it's a
or like make it super anatomically
correct
a lot of realism yeah look what what
what
it's true it's for everyone sex is for
everyone if you want to fuck carter just
use your hand
why do why why what's with the props
maybe this is i'm old school
it's like when i'm like carrot top why
do you just do comedy why do you need
all these toys
perhaps it's the same thing i'm like
just go
believe in yourself i don't know in
covet times
i've wash your hands wash your sex toys
wash your sex toys
yeah you got to clean them i'm pretty
sure they felt i don't yeah i don't want
to have to
you ever been in a sex toy store i have
you ever noticed they wear buttons that
say stuff like ask me about anal
no or be like want to hear about
cunnilingus like
not really i want you to not look at me
until i'm and you can talk me when i
leave
who's coming in like i have some quick
some quick cues
okay just want to know like how many of
the anal beads should i be putting it
like
what are you asking these people i feel
they go to training for this what's the
training
[Laughter]
if you work at a sex toy shop yeah what
is it they're just like ma'am
this is my favorite right now i'm
actually wearing three of these right
now
like what is what is the training for
that